Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 98th
It's not a 98 episode, no?
Huh?
What do you mean?
It's... Ruffians, it's a 98 episode.
No!
That's scary.
98, yo!
Yes, you know what the Ruffians are saying.
98 yo!
I'm not think about it.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Wow, not 98!
See now, Moco-chan, you confuse Ruffians too!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's a show hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Have you had breakfast yet?
What?
Ruffians.
Breakfast?
Not just like, oh I had a coffee.
No.
Did you have bread?
Rice?
Coffee doesn't count.
Eggs?
Toast?
FUWAMOCO!
You did!
Not yet?
Oh sure, yes.
Breakfast is good.
A midnight snack?
Not pizza.
Ban gohan tabita yokatta.
Toast.
Just coffee!
Have something more!
Okay!
I want salt.
Bite eye.
Salt sounds good.
There's been another... Another sighting.
I thought that you said there was breakfast prepared.
Not another breakfast!
No.
Not another breakfast.
Another peron sighting.
But there'll be breakfast after.
Let's see.
Where was Pero sighted then?
De-den!
Oh!
I don't think there's any breakfast here.
Is this where Pero's been hiding this whole time?
Get it!
Whole time!
Because he's in a...
Maybe this is his new doggy house, Ruffian!
Yeah!
You know, I can very thankfully say our dog house is much nicer than this, though.
Yeah.
Maybe just a bit.
Yeah, I think that maybe the rest of Advent wouldn't want to have a sleepover with us if, you know, our place kind of looked a little bit like this.
You know, we still don't really have much furniture or dishes.
It's very similar.
But it's not quite like this.
Although you know what?
I do think that maybe Biboo could probably sleep on that hole too.
Yeah, she does like sort of cramped spaces.
The hole does look pretty comfy.
Ruffians, do you think we should get maybe some housewarming gifts for Pero?
You like the pink wall.
The one nice thing?
This potato is not nice!
Does he deserve some housewarming gifts?
Nah.
He doesn't need them.
Yeah, he has some clothes.
Some clothes.
Does he have a hoe?
I think he has a hoe.
BAU BAU!
We wouldn't want too much dreams, huh?
Yeah.
Some windows!
Ruffians, you can be in charge of that.
I don't want to get any splinters.
Yeah.
Well, you can't see it, but there was some traffic columns in there too, so hopefully they can get rid of those so that maybe it's not too drafty in there too.
Traffic columns don't make a good pillow.
I don't think there's any cars coming by.
BAU BAU!
I guess the good thing about not having any windows is you don't need any curtains, right?
True.
Made it easy.
Bright side to everything.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO!
We finally did it!
It kinda made me wait a long time.
A very long time.
But we were finally able to chat long enough to read all the Super Chats!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
From the period while we were moving to Japan!
Yeah!
It took us a solid 7 hours to read what we had left, but we had so much fun, you know, just being silly with you and talking about all the things we've been up to and experiencing!
I don't know if it was the same for you Ruffians, but the time for us went by in a flash.
Yeah.
We're just like, okay, we're just gonna chat with the Ruffians today.
Then all of a sudden it was seven hours later.
I should know too.
Yeah, it felt like that.
We just love chatting with you Ruffians.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for always supporting us and also for waiting so long for us during the bonkers time that we've been kind of going through since we got to Japan.
Yeah.
We still have the free chat from when we were moving last time.
We haven't forgotten.
No, no, no.
So, thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you for continuing to be patient.
Thank you!
Yeah.
On the other hand, though,
Why'd I notice Ruffians, you know, when we play dog organized neatly?
This week, it's a bit of a super busy one for us.
Is that a bit?
Yeah, like every week this summer.
Yeah.
But, uh, FUWAMOCO, our Ruffian battery, I don't know, it's very low.
Very low.
Like maybe we need to just get a new battery?
Yeah.
We need you.
So, we're forcing some streams into our schedule.
Display everything!
Yay!
Yeah.
You know, that means that now we're gonna have to do a little bit...
We're catching up again.
But it'll be okay!
We'll be able to chat a lot after Minecraft on the weekend.
Thank you always, Ruffians!
Moving and everything and all the busy, bonkers times.
It's kind of been the perfect storm, but this whole waiting for FUWAMOCO, it won't happen again.
Thank you, Ruffians, for being patient!
We love to make the Ruffians cry!
You love to make Fuwamoco cry and say things like that.
Today is a celebratory day.
Gonna start the day off on the right paw.
Yeah.
Yeah, cry for happiness.
Oh!
Is that what you meant?
Oh.
That's what you meant right.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
I think you've been waiting for this, right Ruffians?
Well, maybe a couple days ago.
I kinda mentioned
Fuwawa!
I had an epic dream!
An epic dream!
Yeah!
A fluffy dream, a very fluffy dream!
Ruffians!
You know how sometimes, you kind of, you know the times when you take like a small nap in the middle of the day because, you know, you're kind of starting to fall asleep while you're thinking about something.
And it's just like, oh, that's not a good sign.
Yeah.
All of a sudden you're like, oh, I didn't sleep.
Well, I decided that, okay, I need to take a really quick nap.
Just 30 minutes.
Yeah.
And, oh my gosh!
I had an epic dream.
I think it took you longer than 30 minutes to explain it to me.
Yeah, it's-
I don't know, my dream must have been going at like two times speed.
Only two times.
I don't know.
It was a lot that happened.
Are you ready for it, Ruffians?
I don't know, it's just one of those dreams where I'm amazed so much can happen within that 30 minutes.
And when I woke up, I was like, oh, but it was so amazing.
You're gonna take out your new pants!
Wow!
Okay, Ruffians!
Okay, so in my dream... And by the way, I'm gonna say, this is a dream.
Completely a dream.
I did not fabricate, make up any portions of this story, okay?
This is exactly how it was in my dream, okay?
Yeah, and I wrote notes so I didn't forget about it, but I don't know if I really needed the notes because it's that big.
It is not made up.
It is not exactly how it was.
Fuwawa's brain went asleep, unfortunately.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
Anyways, in my dream, we were having a super special sleepover party with our holo IAN and JP-senpai!
Yeah!
It was such an amazing party!
It was like a sleepover party, but it was like a rented venue, like a hotel or something.
A rented venue!
Yeah, like a hotel, because then it was like...
It wasn't hotel rooms, but it was like bedrooms.
Like, everybody had their own bedrooms.
I don't know how that really worked.
Magic, maybe.
I don't know.
Yeah, that's what happens with hololive.
Magic.
Yeah.
But it wasn't just the Ien-senpai and JP-senpai!
But also Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy were there!
And other senpai's parents were there too!
Yeah, everybody was there.
I don't know.
It was just such a fun and chaotic atmosphere.
You know, there's yummy food and drinks and desserts and everyone was wrangling.
This senpai talking with this person and everything.
And some other puppy was there and she was talking with Biboo.
And they were just having such a great time talking.
They were like, oh yeah, FUWAMOCO.
Oh, Biboo, what kind of games do you like?
Oh, Zelda.
Those kind of things.
And then suddenly, Nenechi formed Mama Puppy.
Then you could see Nenechi's, oh, Nenechi's forming Mama Puppy.
Okay!
Biboo was so excited.
She's, yeah, I'm gonna talk with Mama Puppy and Nenechi at the same time.
We're gonna have an awesome conversation.
It's gonna be so much fun.
And then, when Mama Puppy picked up the phone,
It just turned out to be Mama Puppy's friend and the phone was just kind of bugging out.
So Biboo is disappointed.
Not Nenechi.
Yeah, you know.
It kind of makes sense because you know Nenechi is cooler and cuter than Mama Puppy's friend.
So it makes sense to be kind of disappointed.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, I was just so amazed, a little surprised.
Just a bit.
Yeah, but she looks so pretty and cool like a shoujo manga heroine.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was so much force, so much strength.
Yeah, and I kind of wanted to get back at her.
So then I picked her up, and I spun her around!
And then, she did it to me again!
She kame-doed you again!
Not the kame-doe, we're just spinning each other around, like picking each other up and spinning each other around.
No more friend things.
Yeah, we're just laughing and laughing.
It was so nice!
Counter-attack!
I could feel the reverberation in my bones.
When Rui-senpai was like, pick you up, spin you around and around, and then BAM!
Into the wall!
Kind of thing.
So strong!
Oh yeah!
It was really powerful, and then it was just so nice talking and laughing.
Okay, this is not the end of the dream, no, Ruffians, this is nowhere near the end of the dream, okay?
No, no, no.
Continue, continue!
But there was a lot going on, so then I saw Nerissa!
Yeah, and I was just so happy, because suddenly Nerissa had all this obscure knowledge about Bishoujo Game and the companies and the staff who work on them, and I was able to talk to her about a bunch of different things that I never thought I could.
So you were like, Nerissa, more if you could talk to her about that sort of stuff?
I don't know, I was just really happy and excited.
You know, we were talking about this old visual novel that was getting a new remake and all this stuff.
And I was like, wow, Nerissa, I never knew you were interested in these things as much as me!
She kind of kept it hidden, that's not very nice.
Yeah.
And you know, it was like a, I don't know, we rented a hotel or something, right?
So it was like a big company-wide toast introduction thing kind of going on.
And there was all these tables and everyone was sitting there and having nice food.
And so we had to
FUWAMOCO
And so it was Moco-chan's turn!
And her instructions were to introduce something you like, like your favorite thing, and then her name.
So Moco-chan!
Moco-chan said that her favorite drink is nenjyan, which is like a throat syrup that we've been drinking a ton recently because we've been practicing singing along.
I like it, but it's not my favorite drink!
She was like, I like it so much.
I like ninja.
And she took a sip of it from her glass that she was holding.
And then she started getting really visually sick.
And so I was like, oh, this is kind of embarrassing.
Moco-chan, what are you doing saying this is your favorite thing and then getting sick because you took a sip of it?
But I could tell it was gonna be bad.
Ruffians!
So Moco-chan was kind of like stumbling, kind of getting close to like a table that had a whole bunch of people eating at it.
And so I kind of hurried along with her to the table.
And I picked up this really nice glass centerpiece in the middle that kind of looked like it could hold some liquid.
And then Moco- I did it just in time because then Moco-chan threw up clear- Do you know that thing's called Orbeez?
She threw up clear Orbeez into it.
They're like beads that hold water.
Yeah!
I don't know, it was kind of like... It became a beautiful centerpiece, kind of.
But the girl that was across from her on the table was super rude and she was all like, That's so gross!
I can't believe it!
I can't stand people getting sick in front of me!
And Ruffians...
I can feel the anger that coursed through my body then.
I got so mad at her!
And I was all like, HA!
What?
It's not like she wanted to get sick!
How could you be so rude?
Have some compassion!
And then the lady was just like, I just don't like it.
It's gross.
And we got into this huge brawl!
Fists were flying everywhere!
Everyone was just, ARGH!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Dishes were breaking!
And other members were trying to hold me back!
But!
I prevailed!
And I won the fight!
And then she was all like, Oh Fuwawa!
You're so strong!
You were right!
I'm so sorry!
What is your wisdom?
And I told her that she needed to have compassion and that because she didn't, she lost the fight.
And that my three wisdoms were compassion, confidence, and loving yourself for who you are.
Those are my wisdoms.
And she was like, wow.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
And that was it!
I went over to the food and drink tables and they had enemies.
They had this amazing smoothie bar!
So I made myself a really good smoothie.
It had like mangoes, like fresh mangoes, bananas, and strawberries.
It was so good.
People around me were really envious of my smoothie.
They were like, wow, that looks like such a good smoothie.
Can I have a sip?
No.
And then, I was kind of wandering around.
And I went into Nerissa's room.
I don't know why.
I don't know if it's the room that Nerissa is going to be sleeping in.
And I thought, oh, this is interesting.
Because I found... I found some of my underwear there!
And it wasn't like it was suspicious or anything.
I was like, oh!
This is where these went!
I finally found them!
Yeah!
More underwear!
And then just kind of went on my way.
Yeah, not suspicious.
Yeah.
And then I bumped into somebody who's really, really cool.
Like they kind of look like, um, uh, what's it?
Harley Quinn, they had like a bunch of colorful hair and makeup and cool clothes, really fashionable.
And so I asked her, like she kind of looked like she was lost.
So I asked her if I could help in Japanese for some reason.
And she responded back to me in Japanese that she was Calli-senpai's manager.
And she was looking for Calli-senpai to give her a bunch of gifts from fans.
So, I just kind of pointed her somewhere.
I really had no clue where Calli's sofa was, but I was sure she was around.
Yeah, it's a big party.
Yeah.
But, she was super cool.
She really looked like she just came out of a comic book.
Yeah.
And then, I, like, you know it's been busy, a busy party, I go into a brawl.
So I decided to go take a rest on a sofa.
And I noticed that Kevin Lamar
Arrival.
But, uh, I did, I did make out some of the things he said, and his words I remember very vividly.
These are the exact words that he said, he said to the interviewer.
I can't believe I made bank singing rap songs about cheese.
Yeah, and then I woke up.
It was crazy Ruffians!
What?
And this is why I don't let mama tell me her dreams anymore, okay?
Yeah.
This is what it is like, okay?
Is there any reason to it?
No.
Yeah.
That was my dream.
Her best dream ever.
Yeah, in 30 minutes.
Who knew?
Who knew I could have such a dream like that?
I love you.
That's what it's like!
There's too much detail!
What's the punchline?
There is no punchline!
It's a dream!
It was 13 minutes of dreams!
And this is why I don't like her!
I don't need to know it!
I didn't even tell you the color of the sofa either.
That's the thing.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
After that, I feel a little tired.
Do you need a nap?
Do you need a bit of a...
Me up!
Are you gonna make us a really amazing fruit smoothie, Moco-chan?
No!
I could if I wanted to, but I don't want to.
What are you gonna do then?
It's not an amazing fruit smoothie, but... What about a pup talk?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's been a while, but it's that time again!
It's time that you're gonna listen up because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Have you been a bit busy recently, Ruffians?
You know, somehow it's gotten a busy time of year.
Right?
What do you mean?
It's always?
Well, maybe, but anyways!
Despite being so busy, you're here right now!
You woke up!
And you're gonna do amazing today.
You might doubt yourself, but solve that!
You're gonna do amazing today!
Okay?
Don't doubt yourself.
You're wrong!
Everyone else around you believes in you!
I believe in you!
So, you have to cut that out and start to believe in yourself too, okay?
Repeat after me!
Huh?
I am going to make today a good day!
Okay?
Repeat it now.
Huh?
Things won't go perfectly, but I'll do my best!
Great job.
You know, maybe you won't get everything done that you needed to do, but you'll get a good part of things done.
And that's what matters, okay?
Be proud of the hard work of yours.
I know I am, okay?
No matter what, you can do it!
For sure!
Let's all work hard together, okay?
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It might be the middle of the week, but I think you're good to go!
You can do it!
FUWAMOCO-chan, let's take a look.
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
Our Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Today's Doggie of the Day is Molly!
Molly!
She's so flat!
And long!
She's stuck on the stairs.
That's what I was wondering.
You know, Molly is a wiener dog and has short legs.
So, maybe she's stuck.
What, what dog?
Moc- Moc- Maki!
Maki!
Mali kinda looks like Maki, right?
Why?
Not in jail.
Mali has never done anything wrong.
Mali is free, but she might be trapped on the stairs.
She chooses to be there, okay?
Can she climb down?
Should she roll down?
Both is good.
How does Mali BAU BAU?
BAU BAU!
I think she can be louder.
Oh, really?
There's times when she's quiet, but why be quiet when she can be loud?
That's very chuumoko-chan.
Molly is a hot dog stuck on the stairs right now.
You know, she's doing her all to tell you with those big puppy dog eyes, I'm stuck on the stairs!
But, you know, she really wants you to help her down.
Will you?
Will you help her up the stairs?
She's like your dog.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, it's getting hot outside.
The summer is here, but you're still making sure to stretch those paws, right?
Right!
Well, for today I read on a book, we have De-den!
A sudden bunny!
I like cicadas, but suddenly flying onto you.
It's a bit much.
Did you get stuck?
Kinda looks like a frog.
I don't know which one would be better if it was a cicada or a frog.
I don't know.
I don't think the Ruffians like it either.
A frog?
Right, it looks like a frog.
It's a cicada though.
I don't know, it's pretty amazing to be able to take a photo like this.
You didn't panic.
Right.
You'd scream.
You think so?
It kinda looks like, you know, just a cicada shell, but nope.
Nope, he's still in there.
I would definitely smash it before looking at it.
Reflect.
I don't think that's an answer.
But, uh... Oh, Pony!
Hopefully he didn't get stuck in your hair once he flew away!
No!
That would be really scary!
I'm glad that you were okay with it.
And that he found a good friend.
Yeah.
And... A++ on the photo.
Today's Question of the Day we have... De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
I know it'll be your first time watching Hachi, A Dog's Tale, right?
With the Doggy Pack this weekend, right?
Yeah!
I want to ask you, do you know the story of Hachiko?
Heard about it before.
There's a memorial statue of him outside Shibuya Station in Tokyo.
Yeah, we're really excited to watch it together with the Doggy Pack.
But we chose it because we only have like a really light understanding of the story and what happened, I think.
So we wanted to watch it together with you, Ruffians.
Especially, you know, because recently, Nerissa, it seems like Nerissa saw the movie and it really touched her.
Yeah, and she wanted, you know, I was out with Nerissa and she saw...
A bunch of Hachi merch that she really wanted to buy, so I was like, maybe I should learn a bit more about Hachi.
We're looking forward to it!
Ruffians, you know much about Hachiko.
I think the movie is really popular though.
We're looking forward to it, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions.
I'm sure, Ruffians, there's more than a few of you that want to be a bigger part of FUWAMOCO Morning.
Right!
Yeah!
So if you do, use the hashtag FWMCMORNING and send us pictures of the walks that you go on!
And maybe you have a doggie of your life where you can make them a Doggie of the Day!
Yeah!
You know, if you have any questions, we have very good questions all the time, Ruffians.
Ask us, okay?
Yeah!
Or maybe you see Pero out and about.
Please let us know, okay?
Report it, okay?
BAU BAU!
For our next stream, we have... Donkey Kong Country 2!
We've been playing Donkey Kong Country 2 together on our SNES.
Now the question is...
Iceness has been doing its best, but apparently...
Well, I think it might have went off once.
I don't know.
But we're gonna see together with you, Ruffians, what kind of state it is in.
We don't know the answer, but we will see.
And then we'll have a bunch of fun playing Donkey Kong Country 2.
It's been one month and two weeks.
How?
We'll see what happens.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
We're gonna be playing Donkey Kong Country 2, but also more Touhou!
My senpai taught us a bunch, so we're gonna see just how much we've improved since then.
Kanako again.
Right.
We're gonna be playing also Membembe!
Membembe!
Not a spelling error!
Membembe Radio!
It's a Japanese ending.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us today through the archive!
Here is your FUWAMOCO reward!
It's BAU BAU Fluffy Dream!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Dustin King!
BAU BAU!
Gabito Boboni!
Kaede Nobos!
BAU BAU!
Mofukuroi!
Dameron!
BAU BAU!
Eldori!
Karakara!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!